abent New York wird ih präsentiert V
Swiss der Airline
wo
bringt New York stolz schön faszinierend
die vielleicht legendärste Stadt der
Welt aber auch hektisch und chaotisch
wirleiten Schweizer und schweizerinen
die deno hab dort ein neues Leben
aufzubauen eine Herausforderung nicht
umsonst heißt es wer es in New York
schafft schafft es überall auf der
anderen Seite bietet die Stadt
demjenigen der es wirklich will nach wie
vor unbegrenzte
[Musik]
Möglichkeiten fashion district
manhattten Daniela Fischer schugerman
war 26 als sie nach New York zog sie
folgte ihrem
Herzen hab mich verlibt in Nil und Gott
sei
Dank New York
pitzburg ja einzige Grund
ich Weg aus der Schwiz Neil Schug ist
Saxophonist und hatte in Zürich einen
Auftritt Spiel
total über 8 Millionen Menschen leben
hier im Big apppple darunter rund 14 000
Schweizerinnen und
Schweizer stamft Connecticut eine
gemütliche Kleinstadt 64 km nördlich von
New York es ist kurz nach 6 Uhr urmacher
Harry Beutler ist auf dem Weg zur Arbeit
in die City der Arbeitsweg eine Stunde
hin eine zurück eine typische
Pendlerstrecke die der 55-Jährige
täglich zurücklegt so wie wie 2
Millionen andere New Yorker
auch ke andere
Möglichkeit gesch der Stad
und Land
und das ist so das kann jetzt J
natürlicht und wenn ich nicht ma
vermessen 1985 geht Harry für die
Schweizer uhenfirma Rado nach New York
dort lernt er seine Frau Heidi
kennen das Angebot erhält ein eigenes
Geschäft zu eröffnen fasst er einen
Entschluss er bleibt ja mit morgen W vom
Bahnhof noch ins geschaft laufen ganz
impante Stadt mit de hoch Gebäuden so
und
dann und das ist interessant wenn ich
danke D eig gescha mit New York h und ja
stellt ganz ganz
super Chinatown hier lebt die Bernerin
Anna Kissling die 34jährige kam vor 7
Jahren nach New York lange hat sie fest
für eine große Werbeagentur gearbeitet
und sollte sogar befördert werden doch
statt die Beförderung anzunehmen macht
Anna etwas Unerwartetes sie kündigt hier
wir man Hal immer wieder motiviert
irgend Neues zu machen mir wird echt
dafür gratuliert aber wenn ich jetzt Job
Kön oder so das sie l sogar also freue
sich duf und
neu Projekt mit frei
schwizobach nach der
Sicherheit nichted so glücklich J und
and macht und klapp
Rechtfertigung versucht als fashiony Fuß
zu fassen und genießt ihre
selbständigkeitte Linie entworfen zwei
Prototypen sind gerade fertig geworden
am Wochenende wollen sie damit ein Video
drehen also das
istier zi verschiedene also zi
verschiedene Ex Material das wir die
mater nur für
video
wiequpiration
flüid
steh den beiden bei der Ausarbeitung der
Entwürfe zur
Seite ja ist super also
kein
Design
Charakter doch bei der Tunica von Anna
gibt es ein Problem der Ausschnitt ist
etwas tief
geraten
[Musik]
was tun für nachbessern fehlt die Zeit
um dieses Problem kümmert sich Anna
selbst
Video und
sauberain improvisieren auch das gehört
zu New
York
ja
okayk ein ganz normaler Morgen in
Midtown Manhattan zwischen Touristen
Straßenkünstlern und Geschäftsleuten
Daniela Fischer sugarmman ist auf dem
Weg zu einem Job ihre Haupttätigkeit
food
Styling Daniela ist gelernte Schneiderin
arbeitete in New York zuerst in der
Modebranche dann für eine
cateringfma jetzt setzt sie Lebensmittel
für Werbeaufnahmen ins richtige Licht
ich finde es macht total Sinn
schön zu machen appetitlich präsentieren
also die sind aus TR und
erasse drüber Leck damit nicht so
schnell schmilzt und die schön Rundform
von
nur Glasse
[Musik]
zu
Daniela wird sehr gut gebucht das hat
auch mit ihren Schweizer Qualitäten zu
tun sind auch immer nett es ist nicht
so
ernst aber ich glaube ich als als
schwizerin hab vieles
stärkers ich bin immer pünktlich z.B ich
bin extrem zuverlässig und das
findet das ist nicht selbstverständlich
schätze das All sehr istich schwierig
gut die Arbeiter find aber ich schaff
gern mit der scha einach viel
meh die W das nein das
Abfall der Madison Square Park in
Manhattan hier ist der New Yorker Sitz
der hat sich in der von Männern
dominierten Finanzwelt durchgesetzt die
Juristin aus Zürich berät die oberste
Chefetage in rechtlichen
Angelegenheiten alle wichtigen
Informationen die an die Öffentlichkeit
gehen müssen vorher über Ihren
Tisch was ich sehr schön finden in M Job
be Teil was sehr interessant ist ist
dass ich wirklich so wie bin dass ich
sehr viel gesehen was lauft innerhalb
von der Firma mit oberste
geschaftsleitig und ich bin dann der
legal advisor also der der rechtliche
sie gebe ich Ratschlag das ist extrem
interessant und macht da der Job
wirklich sehr
spannend
1700 Angestellte arbeiten weltweit in
der Rechtsabteilung der Bank geht es um
wichtige Geschäftszahlen ist Christina
die oberste
Instanz dass die Juristin so weit oben
angelangt ist war kein vorgezeichneter
Karriereweg sag Eltern sind sehr off mir
genüber immer immer was ich mus machen
oder jenes und hab mich immer
unterstützt W ich will machen und für
Sie ist alles g was ich machen natürlich
sind sie glaub ich schon sehr stolz auf
mich und hab sehr freut aber wä ich ganz
anders gemacht hätte Christina machte
ihre erste Amerika Erfahrung als
Austauschstudentin später kam sie wieder
um für eine renommierte US-Kanzlei zu
arbeiten vor 10 Jahren wechselte sie zur
gradyy Swiss ein Traumjob mit einem
Nachteil so viel Pause
dem ganz Tag immer
ununterbrochen und die
Meister ihrem und das ist so Kultur da
Amerika ist und schafft wier gichzetig
der
Meister manchmal arbeitet Christina bis
spät in die Nacht doch seit der Geburt
ihrer Tochter muss sie versuchen alles
unter einen Hut zu bringen ja ja ich
schaffe viel und aber l doch dass ich
immer mit me Tochter verbringen das ist
mir schon sehr wichtig und eigentlich
dann der freizit die meistit mit mit me
Tochter verbringen dass man ein G
Familie Hand und das das das ist extrem
wichtig im Alltag erfordert das viel
Organisationstalent auch heute ein
Familienfest steht
an
okay
seit 20 Jahren lebt Christina in New
York doch noch immer gibt es Tage an
denen sie die Stadt neu erobern muss Big
Apple steht auch für einen Dschungel von
Läden und Angeboten sich zurechtzufinden
braucht Zeit oder den richtigen
Tipp
siejährig Party in der Schwiz gemacht
der Schwiz und dann ich
genau und so vi einfach da hat extrem
viel Möglichkeit muss was wie wo
[Musik]
iche m für die
entsz aber die
soes V
Lieblings
eigentlich gerade noch rechtzeitig eine
Sorge
weniger Williamsburg im Moment das
angesagteste Viertel in New York die
Wiege der sogenannten Hipster galt lange
als meltingt von Künstlern und
Intellektuellen in den letzten Jahren
haben Luxussanierungen die Preise in die
Höhe getrieben mittendrin Leben der
Möbeldesigner Patrick weder und seine
Frau Tamika das Paar hat in den 90er
Jahren diese Fabriketage bezogen und aus
der Zeit noch einen unbefristeten
günstigen Mitvertrag ich
glücklich Willam so populär momentan
oder ja unglaublich was da abegangen ist
alles wird
umau luxury
luxury der Hinsicht hab extrem
Glück das Mobiliar hat er selbst gebaut
anfangs aus
Geldnot daraus eine Erfolgstory wurde n
Talent Frau sie ist natürlich sch große
unterstütz für mich sie sind auch schon
se 18 Jahr zammen sie Künstlerin selber
so ganz wunderbar eine wichtige
designshow steht an Patrick soll die
Presselounge Einrichten der icatcher
sind seine großen papmche Lampen wenn
die beim Transport kaputt gingen wäre
das nicht nur schade sondern auch
ziemlich
teuer so groß Skulptur wie dir jetzt ja
der schon fast 300 Stunden
undzutag schon 25 30000 so der Hinsicht
muss ich se RP dass es nicht passiert an
der Fifth Avenue direkt bei der Public
Library hier im vierten Stock ist die
Werkstatt von Harry Beutler 2000 Franken
Miete zahlt der Macher im Monat doch die
gute Lage ist wichtig schließlich lebt
er von der
Laufkundschaft
mittlerweile hat har länger in Amerika
gelebt als in der Schweiz den Schweizer
Akzent pflegt ihr ganz
bewusst
wnwi
sicher
picking nicht
we
normal
die K harry hat eine lukrative Nische
gefunden reiche Leute tragen Schweizer
Uhren und diese müssen ab und zu
repariert werden good
morning
[Musik]
Box
mostently so the last
one was in March of 2012 years AG so
could be very well just be a
battery J
okay was
Speed going
fast Jumping oh I think the second hand
make a big leap every seconds I would
indicate just a battery why check if
it's the battery 20 plus tax I can do it
for you right now if you want to if it's
anything else the battery then you have
to leave it here but let's check the
battery for you
ein Experte für Schweizer Uhren selbst
in der Riesenstadt New York offenbar
eine
Seltenheit ich versuche seit 6 Monaten
herzukommen und habe es nun endlich
geschafft ich fand seine Homepage
vertrauenswürdig außerdem ist er die
einzige Person in New York die von
victorempfohen
wir letzter Test beweist es war die
Batterie Problem gelöst und eine neue
Stammkundin
gewonnen by batterieel lukrativ muss ich
sagen aber mant J Stunden schaff oder z
Stunden irgendwie klapp F wieder vor und
dann dann ist der passiert Daniela wohnt
in Queens sie holt ihre Kinder vom
schulbuss ab 15 Minuten dauert die Fahrt
von der Schule bis ins Quartier
Sunnyside zu lilli ist sechs und geht in
den Kindergarten der achtjährige Lon ist
schon ein drittglässler und der hat
heute etwas ganz außerordentliches
gefunden geh se die Jacken es ist so
heiß
was für den Schatzsucher und Schwester
Lilli ganz nach schweizart das
immerich das macht mich jetzt
ehlich
fer
[Musik]
Daniela gefällt ihr Leben hier als
freiberufliche bleibt dir genügend Zeit
für die Kinder bei den Hausaufgaben
hilft sie gerne mal
mit das Schulsystem ist allerdings ein
Thema das Ihr immer wieder zu schaffen
macht da ist halt alles hektischer
und Sch ke
Geld sind viel meh Kind in
Klass
Katastrophe das ist ehlich einzige W ich
mE schlechten wo mich mag dass
ich nicht die optimale
ausbildtimalingen ist gen hinter Haus
York
[Musik]
Seltenheit Papa Neil kommt nach Hause
mit guten Nachrichten für
Daniela sie hat nämlich eine neue
[Musik]
Geschäftsidee
Schweizer Bratwürste für Amerika Leon
beschäftigen andere
Sorgen ist eine Größe in der New Yorker
Szene ein Leben in der Schweiz wäre
keine Alternative für
ihn es ist nicht ein ist ein
komomiss wir
die es wäre wenn wir in der Schweiz
leben würden das ist der schwierige Teil
wenn man mit jemandem aus einem anderen
Land zusammen ist das ist
hart für Anna ist das Leben
selbstbestimmter geworden für den
videodre mit ihren Tunikas benötigt sie
noch Accessoires Anna nutzt ihre
Kontakte wo sie kann den Schmuck le Sie
sich von einer Bekannten der Designerin
Michelle
Campell
solche Deals erleichtern das Leben auch
die Designerin profitiert vom leeschäft
aber das ganze ist natürlich
Vertrauenssache der Verkaufswert dieser
Stücke ist
6000 grob
geschätzt ihre benefit ist d sie
natürlichwt w anwer im HFT wo das
publiziert wird oder im Abspann von
Video das benannt wird al so Zage ich
W od PR sie so Aufmerksamkeit für Linie
michelle ist Anna bereits einen Schritt
voraus sogar das forbs Magazin hat schon
über die Designerin berichtet
hoffentlich ein gutes Omen für Annas
erstes eigenes
Projekt ja me das ist perfekt was in New
York aber passier definitiv sicher
extreme Inspiration und ma
die Kleider sind fertig der Schmuck ist
da das gilt zu feiern mit dem Video
wollen Anna und Freundin Jes nun
Investoren gewinnen der heutige Tag ist
zumindest mal ein guter
Start wie ein typisch undtypischer New
York Tag und darum ist so amazing new
York einach das ist für mich darum ich
New York ich weiß nicht New York das
cool und so
sondern Dur und B best Freundin nach auf
derchterasse und Klinge
[Musik]
mitilding zurück in
Williamsburg
aufwagen seine
gr
PR über 300 Aussteller zeigen Küchen
Möbel
wohnacessir der Aufbau ist allerdings
ziemlich
chaotisch
Moment wir momentan aber das wird sch
gut Platz machen
das desarriere als Hausmeister ein Mann
der Tat mit kritischem Blick so ja hat
und
soisorischürlich schon wie
schwizmäig infrastrukturell Amerika
generell find aber ja die probier das so
schnell wie möglich und jant
sich gut sind seine Lampen hier
deponiert Patrick Vorahnung bewahrheitet
sichwundert mich eigentlich nicht aber
ja zum Glück ist jetzt
passiertellig wenigens sehr
wertvollunterestanden
oderichmäig oder
so ja die machen das
jich Hinsicht ja Verst ich sch
mus doch irgendwann ist das Gröbste
geschafft Patrick und seine
designerkollegen können sich um die
Details kümmern Präzision und Perfektion
bloß ein Klischee oder wie sehen die New
Yorker den gebürtigen
Schweizer amerikan scher muss
prz ock automatisch Qualitätsprodukt
schusslich made in New York aber in der
Hinsicht ist das natürlich schon ein
Vorteil die
apperzeit wer bereit ist für ein
zweizimmer Apartment bis zu 1000 Franken
im Monat zu zahlen findet hier eine
exklusive
Nachbarschaft so wie chra und Ehemann
Greg von Tochter Lena rückt näher noch
fehlen ein Taufkleid und
Schuhe wir
getau
ladeninhaberinbine kommt aus Hamburg und
hat ganz
vieleleider
hat etwas ganz anderes im
[Musik]
augeow
schne mit Gre oder in der Bank spricht
Christina
Englisch dass Sie hier ab und zu deutsch
sprechen kann heimelt Sie an welche
Größe ist sie denn groß ja ich glaube
ich
gut super ja das schön so eine bezieh
zeigt ein wie international statt ist
das so viel der ganze Welt und das super
das ist was mich fasziniert an New York
die das ist ja so ein bisschen
nachbarschaftsort das ist schon se
häufig dass man Stammkunden hat die
kommen einmal pro Woche rein und
vielleicht auch manchmal einfach nur und
das wächst schon so dass es so ein
bisschen Freundschaft und kaufen eben
zusammen geht miteinander ein guter Kauf
für Lena sie hat jetzt ein neues
Stofftier aber immer noch kein Kleid auf
in den nächsten Laden exklusive
buoutiken gibt es an derzeit
genug so einfach wirklich so viel schön
leider aber ich GL
überle sehr speziell und ein ja
[Musik]
jetzt
überle vor Jahren schon haben sich
Christina und Greg ein penthus
gekauft fester Bestandteil der Familie
ist len
n Herausforderung den Alltag mit einem
Kind zu
organisieren wir arbeiten beide Vollzeit
aber wir bekommen großartige Hilfe von
unserer Nanny Tessi sie macht Dinge
möglich die sonst einfach nicht möglich
wären mit der Geburt von Lena wurde aus
dem Paar eine Familie eine ziemliche
Umstellung wenn man als Geschäftsfrau
spät noch Mutter
wird ja am Anfang sicher unsicher mach
richtig mach nicht richtig und ich glaub
mit der immer lock und denkt ja ich mach
jetzt einfach so wie für mich richtig
danke und gar nicht viel lassen und
überlege sondern einfach machen wie man
denkt dass es
gut die Taufe rückt näher Lenas
partatentante Susanna ist extra aus
Argentinien angereist wo auch Christina
6 Monate gelebt hat im Gepäck ein
Geschenk für das
[Musik]
partatenkind
sus
argentinie
überras das super schön natürlich viel
schönerft super be
zu so schön undtin mir
superf und
schau gefeiert wird auch in Stamford
conneut
urmacher Hari und seine Frau Heidi haben
zu einem gemütlichen raglettabend
eingeladen da braucht ein paar
Vorbereitungen die beiden haben sich vor
30 Jahren im Schweizer skicub von New
York kennengelernt Harry gewann Heidis
Herz mit einer ganz und gar
unamerikanischen
eroberungstaktik
mit den amerikanischen Männern mit denen
ich vorher ausgegangen bin war es immer
so man geht Essen oder ins Kino mit har
habe ich alles gemeinsam gemacht wir
waren wandern skifahren Bootfahren wir
haben ein sehr aktives Leben und wir
leben es
gemeinsam es ist nicht so dass er das
mit seinen Jungs macht und ich mit den
Mädels shoppen
gehe dieiden
haben Vornamens nie gelernt trotzdem ist
die Schweiz überall spürbar auch in der
Küche das meiste ist amerikanisch aber
ich habe harys Lieblingsgerichte von
seiner Mutter gelernt was immer ein
bisschen ausprobieren bedeutet wegen der
Sprache die ersten Male habe ich häufig
zu viel Zwiebeln benutzt oder Knoblauch
also muss man
experimentieren jetzt kann ich
Rahmschnitzel was war das andere Wiener
Schnitzel und Schinken wie heißen die
noch
har
schinkenipf Harry und Heidi sind
gesellige Menschen beinah jedes
Wochenende treffen Sie sich mit Freunden
ein paar Schweizer sind auch darunter
doch im Grunde ist ihr Freundeskreis
sehr
international gem aus eigener Kraft
fragt man ihn zur Einwanderungspolitik
seiner alten Heimat bleibt der
diplomatisch wür sagen das speziell für
Schwiz ich glaub das trifft zu auf
Amerika Jes Land dass man der richtige
mittelwg finde ich glaub Zier hatte für
Schwiz und so W ich ganz sicher sagen
die das Recht dass sie mal Möglichkeit h
so mit Schwiz gewonnen und so dass man
einachade allenimmt ich glaub das ist f
unmöglich aber ich glaub das
Politiker find und gute lös
[Gelächter]
finden English
per
ein neuer Tag in New York mehr als ein
Drittel der 8 Millionen Einwohner sind
ausländischer Herkunft eine magische
Mischung genau deswegen kam Patrick vor
20 Jahren nach New York nahezu ohne
Englischkenntnisse das Chaos der
Großstadt war damals wie eine Droge für
den jungen
Schweizer am Anfang hat mich das extrem
fasziniert das hat mich daszogen oder
jetzt noch noch so lange Z hier und da
kom
scht ich langsam gen vom hektischen oder
und dann ged wo dann z
oders Energie natürlich klar ich s
Wochen schwi ich das
sch heute wird New Yorks größte
Designmesse eröffnet patrick hat die
Lounge gestaltet der 42-Jährige hat sich
als Designer etabliert seine Möbel sind
Einzelstücke seine Kunden
wohlhabend ein Sideboard kostet schnell
mal so viel wie ein
kleinwagenut New York so großes
grundesreis natürlich collector jeder
möchte spezielles und jetzt wie jetzt
die wo wo wo da stell das ist das wäre
die Schwiz Vers der ganze rmen ist
natürlich viel in Patrick Lounge
herrscht Hochbetrieb die Presse ist da
auf der Suche nach neuen Trends Patrick
papm Lampen stechen ins Auge jetzt ist
Networking angesagt denn gute Presse
bedeutet neue
Kunden natürlich der EV sehr wichtig
warum ist das he
die groß magazines werde da und die
triff sich quasi Lounge das bringt
natürlich sehr viel businessmäig oder
aber ja es ist natürlich so
sch normal aber muss man
machen wohlfühlen wäre anders oder
anders ausgedrückt networking ist nichts
für den talentierten
Praktiker
Amerikaner sind natürlich schon meh im
Small mäßig für mich ist das eigentlich
nicht so einfach aber am li natürlich
mir kreier und nicht wirklich so social
aber das muss
natürlichag mit Social
Media Twitter alles und Instagram
Facebook wasuft
[Musik]
oder den aber ja das ist das ist sch gut
so
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja im Stadtteil Queens fern ab von
Straßenschluchten und Hektik in
Manhattan das Zuhause von Daniela und
ihrer Familie seit 13 Jahren lebt die
zircherin in New York sie arbeitet zwar
als foodstylistin aber eigentlich hat
sie einen anderen großen Traum mit
Schweizer kalbsbrat Würsten will sie ihr
eigenes Business
aufziehen es ist Sonntag morgen früh die
Kinder Lili und Leon sind noch ein wenig
verschlafen morgen stimmig noch verkauft
sie die Bratwürste nur übers Wochenende
am streetfood
Markt P Würst lad
Auto
und
Babys
jetzt grilliere
ganzag wird sie heute
[Musik]
begleiten Geschäftsidee
überzeugt alle die ihre Bratwurst essen
sind
begeistert New York ist anders als das
restliche Amerika Essen hat hier einen
großen
Stellenwert tschüss
l jedes Wochenende von Frühling bis
Herbst ist Daniela
unterwegs sonag schaffe ist so hert wenn
man mit Kind Fußball
spiele seit letztem Sommer hat Daniela
die bewlligung für ihre starwurst
Voraussetzung ein Versicherungsnachweis
und ein
grillzertifikat M Test machen für fürweh
wie
Gas Hand den
Gasgrill
C Griller
bist zweimal
dur hat M so nicht
interessiert und dritte Mal ist
gchafft dieser Standplatz kostet 300 am
Tag alleine um diese Kosten zu decken
muss Daniela 40 Bratwürste
verkaufen es ist einfach so mickri
inspiriert hat sie das Restaurant ver
Sternen am
zch ich find so fein und so simpel und
alle
gern groß alt jung R Arm
ich jedes Mal wenn ich schwi bin und vin
und seh was für Gold
das
funktionier
WST nur ke
[Musik]
l köstlich genau wie in der
Schweiz aber Daniela braucht einen neuen
Metz ihr Alter zieht nämlich
weg
Lette
Runde nach D Stunden sind die Bratwürste
ausverkauft Daniela improvisiert und
wirft servas auf den Grill nostalgisch
wird sie deswegen aber
nicht wichtig dass ich einmal im Jahr
bin und
D zum Land aber
mir
knapp 2 Stunden von Manhattan entfernt
auf fire Island das Wetter hat
umgeschlagen Anna und J müssen das Video
für ihre Tunikas drehen die Crew ist für
heute aufgeboten die garen sind bezahlt
Anna gewinnt sogar dieser mlichen Lager
etwas optimistisches
ab leider schlech erwet aber eigentlich
Konzept aber konzep
perfekt
stimm sind perfekt obwohl perfekt
istfang das Strandhaus hat Anna von
einem Bekannten gemietet normalerweise
sorgt sie als fashion Stylistin dafür
dass Models richtig angezogen sind nun
bezahlt sie mit der Gage ihrer letzten
Jobs den heutigen Dreh mit dabei ein
stiller
Zuschauer ein Fuchs nachbaro ist ein
Nachbar
sch
gess sch
gellschaft dann geht es für die
hobbymels raus auf den improvisierten
laufstick bei Temperaturen um den
Gefrierpunkt
ganz
Spaß ja aber nicht nur das Video mit den
silbernen Gewändern soll schließlich
Lust auf die Tunikas machen und
Sponsoren
anlocken mit Leidenschaft trotzen die
beiden Freundinnen der beißenden Kälte
Anna und Jes zwei idealistinnen auch das
ist New
York nicht und wenn Kopf und nur zieh
den Wochen mus halt machen no choice ich
glaube ich kann es mit niemand anderem
so durziehen als mit und darum le ich so
und dar s g
und
Bilder der lästige Schnee am Ende ein
Spezialeffekt wenn man das große
Produktion plant hat man da irgendwie
wahrscheinlich 100000 Frank oder doll m
zah dafür dass man künstlicher Schnee
und der B knetzt hat wie im FM besserust
etc und mir eigentlich alles genau da oh
mein Gott perfekt
[Musik]
urmacher har ist unterwegs zu einem ganz
besonderen Freizeitvergnügen dem
Fliegen den Pilotenschein hat er hier
gemacht innerhalb weniger Monate für
gerade mal 4000
Franken
har hat in Amerika Lebensträume wah
gemacht die in der Schweiz wohl
unerfüllt geblieben
wären flügere interessant der
Technik der flüger selber der Flugplatz
zichit wenn der Luft ist
dimensional und und nach links und
rechts und dann natürlich der ganze
Challenge interessant die Kommunikation
mit dem Kontrollturm und starten unds
landen und einfach das ganze V A bis Z
das ist für mir so irgend interessant
und so schön und wenn mal in der Luft
ist die genü die Skyline von New York
manhten istür sehr interessant jetzt
noch 20 oder 30 Mal wo ich das schon
gemacht hab freiheitsstatu V geseht das
ist Perspektive wo nicht viel wenn auf
ne York kommen ja so V dem
her gute die Sache passiert da mir in
[Musik]
Amerika in der nächsten Folge Christina
und Greg feiern die Taufe ihrer Tochter
die ganze Familie ist angereist ein
großer Tag für die kleine
Lena außerdem on the road again mit
steel Harry und Heidi unterwegs zur
Oldtimer Messe da glänzen Chrom und
Augen
gleichermaßen
und bei Daniela geht es um die Wurst die
foodexertin auf der Suche nach dem
richtigen
Metzger guter Geschmack ist
[Musik]
gefragt abentür New York Swiss
präsentiert wurde der Airline
wo bringt